when you buy an asset that's illiquid
like real estate sometimes
that is it's diverse in the sense it's a
different asset class but it does not
provide for liquidity
in times of stress you need to
understand where there's risk
you can't value every asset the same way
i need
skin in the game so for those of you
that are sending me all these
prospectuses that are not willing to
give up
9.8 don't bother
now i i want to go back for a moment to
what
uh your mother told you about
diversification uh
some folks uh you know we've got warren
buffett's view on diversification
we've got other folks views on
diversification that
maybe when somebody starts out they
shouldn't diversify much so they can
build wealth and then protect their
wealth later
how do you respond to that you know
diversifying less when you're starting
out
no i understand diversity is important
but so is liquidity i mean you've got to
you have to balance both of those when
you buy an asset that's illiquid like
real estate sometimes
that is it's diverse in the sense it's a
different asset class but it does not
provide for liquidity in times of stress
and so you know one of the tests i asked
everybody to do when they look at their
their their net worth is how much of
this is liquid
how much of it if catastrophic outcome
occurred to my family
a car accident catastrophic illness
whatever
where's the liquidity for me to survive
with if everything i own
is a liquid asset that's not
diversification
and so you need to have some liquidity
in your model
you need to understand where there's
risk you can't value
every asset the same way and liquidity
is very very important and not given
enough respect because in times of
financial stress
it's the liquidity that provides you the
opportunity to redeploy capital so when
i say cash cash
that's pure liquidity when something
corrects and i want to buy it i'll have
the
the you know the the firepower to do it
i'll have that
dry powder waiting to redeploy and i'm
waiting now
so far there's been no correction but
i've lived on
i've lived through lots of volatility
and i know just when it seems to be safe
poopoo happens that's a good point
yeah so a i mean a lot of people are
going to hear that and
they're going to think okay so what
you're saying is all in on stocks
because i could just swipe
up and they're liquid can you speak well
not every stock i mean obviously large
cap
i only own 100 of the s p 500 because i
care about the quality of the balance
sheet above all
the ability for the business model to be
sustained i want to participate in the
cash flow profits in the form of
distributions
you know you can find companies paying
1.5 to 2 percent
of their profits in the form of
dividends and have potential growth of
their of their value
um and so i do that but they're
generally very liquid but when you get
into the micro
stocks or you take very speculative
positions on in things like junior
pharma
you have to understand that there's
volatility there and you need to
mitigate that risk
and so this comes from experience i've
always said i'm a big fan of robin hood
because even though
it's got a lot of criticism it helps 22
million people learn about stocks
you can't even short a stock on robin
hood people don't know that so
i think vlad the ceo there i had a
chance to meet recently
expressed to me his heartfelt concerned
that people didn't blow themselves up on
his platform
and they've done a lot of work to try
and help people uh protect themselves
from themselves
and so i i'm a big believer in um in
learning the ways of the stock market in
that way even if it's only
hundred dollars you're playing with you
can buy fractional shares and start to
understand
portfolio management yeah i mean to one
positive note there on robinhood uh you
had talked about any of these apps you
can download
probably paying big fees for crypto and
i noticed that in the crypto space huge
spreads
uh large fees uh you know spot price is
way off from what you're able to buy or
sell it for
robinhood has been one of those that
even though you can't transfer your coin
i don't even i don't even think you're
actually getting a coin you're getting
like a
you know an index uh it is the one that
seems to be the
cheapest out of all of them it just
consistently has the cheapest price
every time i run experiments
are you bullish on the robinhood ipo
um i am i think it's going to do very
well i think um
you know coinbase is going to do very
well there's a lot of interest in crypto
a lot of interest in trading platforms
um you know it's again
financial services in the end is valued
by
um ebitda or cash flow multiples and
right and right now
because the growth of those platforms
looks so fantastic but when you go and
look at banks
and book values and in the end
you can really hype it up but in the but
unfortunately
over time if you don't if you don't grow
into those expectations of free cash
flow
uh the market re-value revalues you
financial services are generally uh
commodities
banks are commodities um they don't have
anything proprietary from
one to another other than brand and so
it does level the playing field
eventually
how would you value a coin base i mean
obviously their
their numbers here in q1 have been
insane i mean phenomenal growth
and insane cash flow i mean
you're talking about cash flow they got
cash flow does this mean you're plowing
into coinbase
um i think as a trade it'll be
interesting but you know
uh when you start to value cash flow
past 17
times well past the market value you
really got to believe the growth and so
the
assumption about coinbase is what else
can they sell these people
it's it's sort of like the sofi model
what else can they
sell can they sell insurance can they
sell uh mortgages can they sell
credit rating services can they sell
whatever
and so you once you have once you've
captured the customer how far can you go
is the whole idea that's why it's
interesting to investors it's very hard
to amass a base
of that many wallets really really hard
and so you know getting just past the
first ten thousand is almost impossible
but then past that you can grow into the
millions of them because you found a way
to acquire customers on an economic
basis which they have
so there is value there no question so
it sounds like you're probably
not all in on tesla
the way to play tesla um is is to use
the thesis
of diversification keeping it at a five
percent waiting i bought tesla
at 238 dollars pre-split when my son
became an intern there he now works
there as an electrical engineer
and he made me he made me look at the
company a different way
he said it's nothing it's not a car
company it's it's a it's a data company
it gathers data
it has tremendous value long term and if
you view it that way you should own some
so it convinced me to buy some one day
when it was downgraded
that stock obviously became one of my
best performing positions but every time
it would go blow past five percent i
sold it down to five percent
so now my cost base in in tesla's zero
um
and so and that's how i that's the
discipline i have
i don't let stocks be more than five
percent for very long and i continue to
sell
sell into the strength but i keep my
position and so
you you lose out on all the upside but
the diversification metric you get
is is very very good in volatile times
you don't participate in the full
drawdown
because you profited from your winners
it's just a philosophy that you learn to
appreciate
every time a big position takes a big
nosedive and you let it grow more than
five percent
yeah now i i don't i don't recommend
what i'm about to say and
it'll be a little embarrassing saying it
to you but i'll say it
and i don't recommend this i want to be
very clear about this uh
uh of so about half of my net worth is
in real estate about half is in stocks
uh so uh the portfolio because there's
there's debt obviously against the real
estate
and a little bit against stocks as well
which i know you're not a big fan of
uh but uh of my of the half that's in
stocks
about uh 48 is tesla is that
really bad yeah yeah it is
that's really bad so i get roasted by
kevin o'leary i had to do it
that is that is a very bad idea um
because you saw
a drawdown of 25 or 23 and it's come
back a bit
you know your cost base is probably very
low on tesla
um you know so i would never ever let
that happen in my portfolio
ever so if anything hap if anything
happens to tesla you're going to really
be crying the blues
but you know it doesn't mean but you
thank goodness we met you can fix this
kevin
that's true yeah exactly that's a good
point
so okay well so what would let me ask
you what would you do
with the portfolio we'll lay it out
there so
uh well you didn't tell me your sectoral
weightings i mean you know i could go to
town on your portfolio and tell you
where you're under invested where you're
over invested
at the stock and sectoral level i mean
you know
i would i would prefer in a portfolio
and have exposure to at least
five sectors you know and and at least
20 stocks i mean to me that's i own way
more than that but you know i've got
the only sectors i don't have exposure
to right now are duration risks like
reits
uh energy stocks i don't have any
exposure to right now
i do have exposure to banks but you know
just jp morgan i have some exposure to
financial services
i'm looking for companies that are
really in the sweet spot
for america 2.0 the consumer stocks the
technology stocks
the health care stocks and so my
weighting is a little bit you know full
weightings into those three sectors
um and so then 40 of the sectoral
weighting to others
but i also have geographic exposure i'm
up to 20 in europe now
um which is a first for me because the
values are so interesting there
it's a it's a zip code that people have
hated for a long time but i think europe
low growth right sorry low growth is
oftentimes what people think when they
think of europe right
yeah but all that's going to happen
there is there's going to be tremendous
stimulus poured in by their government
too
and frankly there's 50 stocks in europe
like like roche and nestle
that are really if you think about them
domestic stocks just happened to be
headquartered in another place
i mean those so much american tobacco
sold in
the u.s so i try and find those
companies are representative of sectors
i already own here
and i'm just getting them at a p e
discount in europe
and i don't mind having some currency i
buy them in the native currency so
i've got some exposure swiss franc to
euro to british pound
um there's nothing wrong with that if
you're going to take exposure to bitcoin
you might as well own some other
currencies too
so we'll just see how all that plays out
but you know i think it's early
i think this is going to be a very good
year for equities and i'm very
optimistic
so why no reits you had mentioned reits
were a no-no for you
well reits tend to have a duration risk
so
um i wouldn't want to own a reit that
just has a bunch of
malls in it right now because they have
to go through conversion there's a lot
of optimism that they'll
you know there's some not the name names
but i i owned all those rates i've sold
all of them and i'm glad i did when i
sold them because they're down
significantly from where i sold them
and and i don't see any reason to get
back into them right now we've got to go
through this transitional
period over the next 24 months so i can
see where in commercial real estate i
should redeploy and i will
i just don't see anything attractive you
know you've got an empty building
uh with no tenant being you know people
trying to sell it for a four cap
i don't think so i'm not going to do
that that's not a good idea
there's a reason it's empty you know
it's and so uh
we've got to wait this out a little bit
and and that's one of the reasons you're
being patient i mean oftentimes people's
cash burns a hole in their wallet uh
oftentimes for the negative they spend
it on things they don't need like you
mentioned
i have this problem where when i get
cash i spend it right away to invest in
uh so yeah i don't i don't have that
problem i've learned that this one a
long time ago cash is just another asset
on the balance sheet
it's where it's overweighted right now
we we are overweight
and that's a problem it's it's pushing
down returns pushing down irr
but i've learned uh through conditioning
in markets like this to
keep some powder dry there'll be great
opportunities coming
i don't know where they're going to be
i'm looking at deals every day
every day you know i spend about i don't
know 90 minutes a day going through the
new
which is our deal flow's insane right
now we just have a huge amount of
but you know i try and work with others
and say let's categorize these into
buckets something we'd look at something
won't touch
you know we look at a lot of different
things and we have certain core
strengths we're very good at we have a
tremendous due diligence team
um we are a sustainable investor not
because it's a marketing scam because
the
the
people that we invest beside uh have
those mandates and consumers and the
consumer goods and services company
we've already learned through the blue
lands um you know prime
six i'm an investor in uh this is like
give you a good example i'll just hold
it up
this is a the first charcoal company in
america
that is sustainable it takes uh the the
wastes of
hard grain mills or hardwood mills the
sawdust
compresses them into these incredible uh
incredibly efficient logs that don't
have any waste
material and consistently burn at the
same temperature every time they sell
when they plant a tree
that used to be a corny marketing scam
now it's the number one in demand
charcoal in america every
grocer has customers coming in saying
where's my prime six i want to buy prime
six i don't i don't want to buy this
stuff
that pollutes i want prime six so that
happens right and we're a big investor
in that
that's incredible what do you think
about i know you mentioned energy like
utilities you weren't enthused about
what do you think about like um
like an end phase the solar revolution
and and even to some respects uh
tesla in the energy business well
tesla's different i mean
it's a it's a data company and a battery
company and a technology company
um and is also captured the imagination
of investors worldwide so
it's it's getting an index weighting as
an ev company as well
but a lot of the solar companies have
yet to proven
uh profitability without government
subsidy but i think that's coming
the wind is even worse in some in some
cases there's municipal
restrictions and all kinds of issues but
yet those are
sustainability mandates and they will
get better and better as time passes in
terms of technology
the sector that does look like it's
really going to get killed is
hydrocarbons because you've got ge
declaring they're going to phase out the
combustion engine
or gm gm i should say and um
and you've got you know this mandate
from
every uh federal government level and
uh state that they want to get out of uh
hydrocarbons
so i would say that the companies will
be more efficient at spending less in
cap
x but the pes of all of these once great
energy stocks schlumberger
you know chevron exxon i used to own
those i don't own them anymore because i
think their p's will just keep getting
compressed
and frankly uh when i have you know uh
institutional clients say
did i see schlumberger on your balance
sheet uh
now i don't have to be embarrassed about
it i i say no
no you do see one of the things i didn't
like about the s p
500 like straight up s p 500 index fund
which is probably where you stand as
well is
you get more money allocated to tobacco
companies then you get like starbucks or
target
is is that kind of like that same
feeling you had when folks are saying
why are you investing in these oil
companies
yeah but i believe in the sustainability
model is now perpetual and remains so as
larry thinks letter said a few months
ago you know he's really pushing on
on corporate mandates to fund
sustainability and climate change issues
and you can debate that till the cows
come home but the point is that the
reality
of what is going on and so i don't want
to have to answer to a
institutional client anymore that yes we
have schlumberger
on our index we don't and there's a
reason they don't want to see it there
and they won't
do business with us this is right down
to retail investors they don't want to
see it they don't want to own it so
i i am not telling them what to own i
index for them
and so that that's sort of uh the way i
look at it
yeah uh tesla you mentioned
almost has an index weighting as you
mentioned you just mentioned you
quickly mentioned four or five different
sectors it's in does that mean i could
put five percent into each of those and
justify my 48
well it's a five percent into a stock i
mean your tesla stock
you know your stock should be five
percent of your waiting maybe six at
best
and then you you would take the the
money you made there that you
diversified and you
invested in other sectors that appeal to
you for me right now that's consumer
health care and technology but it
doesn't mean it stays that way forever
it's just that the allocation i probably
own in aggregate close to 900 stocks
around the world
um and and probably the largest position
i might have is five percent in one of
them
and so it's um it's really
a diverse index of
ownership across multiple sectors
multiple geographies and that's my
equities and then i do all these
very highly risky investments in these
small private companies
but i've had some great outcomes there i
think i add a lot of value
as an investor in terms of of helping
them grow and acquire customers
and i know i'm worth that and i you know
when people approach me
i always have a good time when someone
calls me up and says you know we're just
closing around
um we have sales of two million dollars
we're closing around at a 25 million
dollar pre-evaluation we'd love to be an
investor and i say look
that's wonderful i'm very appreciative
you made this offer to me i understand
it's a private
syndicate you're forming i'll make you
an offer based on my value to you
and you can accept it or you don't have
to
but i couldn't care less what your
valuation is i don't care
if you want me to be an investor it's a
very simple rule
i want 12 and a half percent of the
company before the employee option pool
which will drop me down to 9.8 percent
if your pool's
21 22 which it often is i will
in some cases you will give me that
stock and put a long hold period on it
or in other cases
i will buy it or a combination of both
but if i don't have 9.8 percent i'm not
really interested
and uh and then and their answer is
that's outrageous what do we tell our
investors and i say i don't care
but if you want if you want me if you
want me and all the power
i have to get your story out there and
all the customers i can acquire
this is what it takes to engage me and
fifty percent of the time
they tell me to go you know what and the
other half we end up another halfway end
up doing deals
and i'm and i i know my value i'm
extremely good at helping companies grow
i have a fantastic team that does the
same
but this is the power of social media i
have five million followers which i
think the majority of them are investors
or want to be investors
and follow you know my muses about where
i go
and that doesn't mean they have to
invest the way i do but they're
interested
and i bring these issues to the fore and
in doing so
we create a community of people that
want to become investors in various
companies
and i think that's a great job for me to
have it's a useful productive use of my
social media
but i don't do i don't do it for a two
percent holding i don't care about that
it doesn't even get me out of bed in the
morning i couldn't care less i wouldn't
even
wouldn't matter i need skin in the game
so for those of you that are sending me
all these prospectuses that are not
willing to give up
9.8 don't bother
[Laughter]
great messaging so uh it sounds to me
because
when you mentioned you're in 900
different stocks that sounds extremely
diversified i mean
i think studies show that if you have 30
to 50
stocks you almost have you almost mirror
like 95
of the diversity of an index fund yeah
900 that's incredibly diversified
are you being so conservative if i can
say that
on stocks because you're taking larger
risks
in private equity it's an interesting
point but no the reason i own so many
stocks that it can vary from a few
hundred to you know
multiple hundred is i study the draw
down in other words i look at the
history of a stock
in a correction and so if there's if
there is a massive correction 30 40
correction i want that stock to only
participate in maybe
two thirds of that correction and i
define my ownership base
not on upside but on downside protection
i don't need more money
i need to keep what i've got and i want
it to be productive and i want to be
able to distribute six percent so
my attitude is saying i would i covet
much more protection to the downside
than i do
out performance so i'm the reason i'm so
diversified is is those holdings those
individual stocks
have tended to have a history of very
good performance in drawdowns
that's much different than an investor
says all i care about is beating the
indexes
i don't care about beating the indexes
at all
is that uh unique to you though that
you've already
established wealth like why i mean for
the
the 20 25 30 year old watching right now
and they're like look i got i'm they're
looking at their portfolio going dang
i'm 25
in on tesla and and every time it dips
i'm buying more of it you know the buy
the dip culture
like isn't that potentially a great way
to build wealth
it is um it's more rock and roll but
what
invariably happens to that kind of
investment style
is you go through a massive correction
and you get you learn a very important
lesson
the generation that is trading right now
has never gone through a sustained
correction
it hasn't and and that's okay because
it's coming i don't know when
i don't know how what will trigger it
but they will learn their lesson and it
generally happens in your
30s if you have a lot of leverage on
it's a hell of a lesson because you end
up
in a negative net worth position but you
do learn it and i learned that lesson
in my early days i shorted yahoo when it
was 35
and watched it go to 280 and never cut
and never covered the short
i had to wait four years for it to get
back down to twelve dollars that was a
very stupid investment
but it taught me a very important lesson
about the power
and the risk of shorting stocks and i'm
very very very concerned about that now
when i do hedge trading and so i'm very
you know you learn that lesson
it gets ingrained in your dna um and and
i don't make those mistakes anymore
and what i concern myself now with and
it happens to anybody once you turn 40.
preservation of wealth becomes part of
your investment metric
and the various things you do like
diversification and sectoral
diversification we talked about
are part of that so i don't need to beat
the market
i did that already i need to keep i need
to keep what i've got
that's awesome what do you think about
folks who were
very enthusiastic about options these
days robin hood is right there
very much makes options trading
extremely easy and these derivatives
used to be pages that people would never
go to in the td ameritrade or scottrade
days
yeah the thing about options is
particularly writing calls for example i
mean
most people use options do not
understand
how they work and how they should be
used i don't want to sound
you know negative on the use of options
but
let me tell you you know in a bull
market when you're writing calls you get
called away long before the potential of
your stock is realized
and so you're just you're timing you're
trying to time the market when you use
options
very hard to do i'm not against it okay
but i don't use them anymore i don't use
leverage and i don't use options
it doesn't mean you shouldn't it's just
that i've learned over a long period of
time that there's an
additional risk in using options
particularly if you're using
leverage on options because you're
ghosting
the the the mechanics of it dramatically
and that's where people blow themselves
up so if you're going to use options
it's really
worth you know the jarrian brothers are
very good at teaching you how to use
options
i would recommend them to anybody
they're really strong at that
but i don't need to use options anymore
i don't have to
and so if i'm going to go long a stock
i'm going to go along a stock until it's
a six percent waiting i'm going to trim
it down i don't need an option to do
that
i like to i have an expression about
investing i teach everybody that i
i guess lecture with now keep it simple
stupid
because i mean when you get into these
complex straddles
and and callers and all of this stuff
with leverage
sometimes you wake up with a hangover
after going out to a party and you
forget the position you have on
and at 9 45 you just blew yourself up
i mean it's it's that's actually what
happens you got to be careful
oh yeah yeah that's interesting you know
another thing
that kind of goes along with this
portfolio building that i want to touch
on or ask you about at least
is uh i have this theory that you go
through
a phase of life uh you go through your
growth phase
and then you go through like the cash
flow phase uh and
uh sure you can have both but people
regularly ask me oh should i pay down my
mortgage
and a belief i have is that in your
growth phase you don't it's it's
inexpensive money 30-year fixed rate
debt
you don't go for that 15-year loan when
you're in that payoff phase that
retirement phase where you're getting
close to that retirement phase where you
want dividends and cash flow and your
income is going to go down because
you're going to work less hours
then you go for that 15-year mortgage
can you speak to that
idea i would agree with you as long as
it's a
fixed mortgage not a variable rate
mortgage because where that where that
blows up is when rates make a big move
and all of a sudden you readjust
it up on your monthly payment by 20 30
percent that can't happen hasn't
happened recently but
you know if you're not going to be
paying down your mortgage which is often
your best investment because it's a
certainty
when you pay it off versus the
volatility and risk of the overall
markets
it should be fixed rates so you know
you're not and if you're doing that then
i would agree that you
start putting some aside into the
indexes where you have volatility
but when you pass 45 you really
should try and have your mortgage paid
off because you have to be
in the gathering mode and the the debt
on your house remains
uh you know a liability and it will
forever until you pay it off
so i my models are generally you know i
got out of debt
um like when i was crossed into my 40s
and i never looked back and i pay off my
credit card amount
there's no scenario where people offer
me debt where it makes sense
if i if i have cash to deploy why would
i take on leverage
it makes no sense so i i just don't and
i
i go to sleep at night i have risky
positions on but
that you know i don't put it all into
one basket that's the whole point
are you not leveraging your real estate
at all then
um i much prefer i i met a a really
interesting um a really interesting guy
years ago you're making me think back
when i started buying my first homes
renown and then renting them out
he used to buy homes the same way i was
doing it and he
he took me outside and showed me
the house i owned and the one beside it
and he said
your home is a pasta home
this home beside you is a steak
home and i said what the hell does that
mean he said
your home has a mortgage on it
this home that i own because he was
he only was a landlord that was renting
houses beside me is a steakhouse it has
no debt
every dollar that comes out of it i can
go buy a steak with
i can cook it on the barbecue but i
can't eat steak when i have a mortgage
because i don't know what's going to
happen until i pay it off
so you're a pasta guy you can't eat
protein yet
and i it was a brilliant analogy because
he basically said
use the steak house to pay off the pasta
house
get rid of the debt move down the street
which is he was
you know he's an older guy he owned the
whole street i was just a new kid on the
block who just bought one i overpaid
he was trying to buy the house i
overpaid for it but it ended up being a
great investment
but the point was he was right so when i
when i stabilize a storage facility
let's say as i did years ago
i use that cash flow to pay down the
debt and
and that and then when you get the big
correction where there's totally
illiquidity
and all of a sudden guys that are over
11 are blowing up and having to sell
their places at discount prices
there you are waiting to pick up the
pieces it's pasta versus steak
now you get it yeah i mean honestly it's
it's a great argument
i think of uh i never did refinances on
the original properties that i bought
and they're all in southern california
which you're probably not happy about
that
but uh in when the pandemic happened
and the federal reserve on a sunday
reduced rates to zero i immediately
called my lender and said refinance
everything so i figured i'd need cash
for for what was to come
and it ended up probably i think it it
could very well then it sounds weird to
say but it could end up having been one
of the best decisions i've ever made
or ever will make because i had all of
this cash that came to me at the end of
march beginning of april which is the
bottom of the market
and i put it all in yeah but but you
lived through a period of unique time
when for 30 years rates did nothing
except go down that's probably not going
to happen for the next 30. so you were
an opportunist you did the right thing
but the reduction of leverage is always
a long-term strategy that works and so
you use these opportunities as you did
to reduce leverage or at least pay a
lower rate
when on the leverage you had but at this
point in my investment philosophy i
don't use it
i don't need to use it i don't want to
use it and i don't want the covenants
associated with it
they reduce they reduce liquidity and
diversification
i look at all these these you know i do
i don't even sign ndas anymore i
i don't sign anything no people are
always saying you have to sign this nda
before
i show you my deal i said i'm not
signing anything if you want to show me
your deal
that's great if you don't want to show
the deal because
andy like ndas have all kinds of
covenants
that restrict your flexibility in other
unknown situations you're signing an
agreement
that stops you from doing certain things
and you don't know you're going to do
them yet
so my attitude is if the deal is so hot
and so important
it's yours keep it i don't need to know
the stuff you want to keep a secret
because by the way you see this pile
over here these other 40 deals i haven't
had a chance to read these yet
but i'm going to look through these next
so you know it's it's just the diversity
of
in the end what i've learned is and you
know i guess unabashedly when i say this
it's really good being mr wonderful
[Laughter]
i love it uh i want to ask you about
nfts
are you going to get into these or or is
this a is this a big bubble waiting to
burst
no it's a derivative of the digital
economy um you think about what it
promises for
uh the arts and i'm very interested in
music and
i collect art as well modern art i think
there's merit
the because it's a new asset class it's
going to be immensely volatile some of
these have 90
volatility but i think the idea that you
have something that's copyrighted in
perpetuity
that can't be forged is really
interesting and a good idea
and so i i think at the end of the day
they will find their place
i'm dabbling um i'm in a negotiation now
on a particular
piece i don't know if i'll close it or
not it's just it's like my watch
collection
my wife said to me why do you keep
buying those watches
you if you wore three watches a day you
couldn't get through your collection
anymore and i say well as an asset class
is performed she said that's ridiculous
what do you need another watch for and
it's they have performed they're up over
100 in the last two years
i i enjoy the art of watchmaking i want
to support
the people that give up their lives in
the age of 14 to become a master
watchmaker in italy or
switzerland or germany or even england
now and so
those people mean a lot to me and i want
to support them and i buy
their watches i mean i have a watch i'm
wearing right now in fpjorn
you probably have seen this on putin's
wrist this company only makes 900
watches a year maybe 17 of these
it's appreciated over a hundred percent
since i bought it 18 months ago
maybe putin did that to it i don't know
but it doesn't matter it's
it's a piece of art and what about the
uh the art on my apple watch like the
pictures of my children on it well i've
often said about apple watches that's
great
uh you'll probably have to burn in hell
because you wear that you're not
supporting real watchmaking that thing
is a
you know kev that tells you right now
you're 20 off retail if you walk around
with an apple watch on
like that thing is not that that is a
piece of consumer electronic junk
and i and i own apple stock but i would
never be seen dead with an apple watch
on not a chance in hell
so you're probably not happy that not
today but usually i wear two of them one
for my texts and one for my twitter
notifications
yeah that's that's just that's garbage
that's what that is
that's awesome okay uh wow so
uh very interesting insights uh okay so
i think the
we've hit a lot of different things here
i think the the last question then
then i have for you has to do with uh
florida
california this exodus and then and then
maybe one more on port
one last one to wrap up on portfolio you
live in florida did you go to florida
because of the zero percent state income
tax
uh for my operating business yes but i
also moved here for lifestyle
florida and texas are the two big
options uh california new york
massachusetts those states have priced
themselves out of
growing businesses anymore they're going
to have to somehow figure it out
but i'm not waiting around for them to
do that i would never start a business
in any of those states and in fact when
i buy businesses i move them out of
those states
i move recently moved one out of
california northern california
to jacksonville florida coders are much
cheaper here taxes are much better
you're talking about a 17
difference i really like the competition
between states because you've got
you know pretty soon california will be
a vacation a location but you wouldn't
want to start a business there
i would never invest in that state and i
won't invest in new york or
massachusetts either
until they get their poop together
meanwhile down here in florida we're
just
rocking we've got the cultural vibe it's
fantastic spectacular
art scene fantastic investment
environment great mayor for the city
i mean everything's working here it's an
example of what america
can be and an example in texas the same
way
of what we every state should be if you
want to be globally competitive
but you know all that rhetoric coming
out of new york imagine pushing away
amazon with
thousands and thousands of jobs and they
simply said okay if you don't want us
we'll just move to carolina and we'll
we'll employ 25 000 people down here
i mean not to name names but some
politicians just don't get it they just
are so far from reality
that they drive their states right into
a ditch so
i'm not going to fight with them i'm
going to visit i'm going to visit but
i'm not going to
live there i think that's the whole
point the 17
competitiveness for your business are
you talking about your employees being
able to take home more money and they're
in every way florida is better than a
high-tax jurisdiction in every way
access internet employment colleges
research um lifestyle weather
who the hell wants to be near the
northeast in february i mean i
i wouldn't like there's a reason birds
fly south
where do they go to florida they like
the taxes and the weather
that's the whole point well well what do
you say about uh the socal weather i
mean you got mediterranean climate over
there you got that
love socal love soquel love uh to go
work out there
and we make shark tank on the sony lot
love it uh
would never uh take a residence there or
invest a business those guys are
clueless
there'll be there'll be there'll be a
change well i could i could rent
something but
i'd rather just stay in a hotel because
i'm there for you know a few weeks i got
to make sure i'm not there too long the
neck
if you stay there too long you get taxed
at a ridiculous tax rate that's even
in my views on american that's what i
look at and lots of other people are
figuring that out saying why
what do they have that i need so much
that i can't get in texas or florida
we're at that stage now particularly
when they're contemplating raising
corporate taxes
why would you ever start a business
there ever
what you want to do is sell your product
and service there but don't have the
nexus of your
corporation there it's not good for
business so how do i convince my wife
lauren to finally leave california
she doesn't want to leave california for
you mentioned it earlier family and
weather
well simply look at your tax bill each
year i think yours you don't care
well i get it um i would rather have
that money to start businesses with
create jobs in america than
then give it to the federal government
you know you should really uh you should
send her to my
official boot camp for um re-education
okay how do i do that it's expensive i
get a huge royalty it's fantastic
uh so if you had uh real estate here
so i've got like i said 50 of my
portfolios in california real estate
southern california real estate
uh would you just 1031 exchange this
stuff to avoid taxation or or
uh would you put it all into a big
multi-family building in austin or what
would you do
i diversify i'd get some other
geographies i'd sell a couple of
properties and redeploy it somewhere
else just to get diversification
1031 and then what do you for for tesla
stock
you pay some big taxes if you got that
low basis especially in california i'm
paying like 56
out here something insane yeah another
reason to leave another reason to leave
california but i
i never let taxes make investment
decisions for me i i i keep on the
diversification
tax is something you pay you're going to
have to pay it whenever you sell it so
you might as well
stay diversified if you like that video
where do you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe